Hello, and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
Live. I'm your host, Rawkode. Today, we're taking
a look at hacking Kubernetes,
playing some fun capture the flags organized for
us by our friends at Control Plane.
Before we get started, there's just a little
bit of housekeeping. So first, please subscribe to
the YouTube channel and click the bell. This
will get you alerts and notifications whenever we
have new episodes of Rawkode Live.
Next, we have a very active Discord server.
Feel free to jump in there if you
wanna chat cloud native, Kubernetes, and anything in
between.
And lastly, thank you to my employer, Equinix
Metal. They allow me to do this on
their time and leverage their hardware when required.
If you wanna check out a bare metal
cloud, use the code Rawkode.
This will get you $200 of compute, which
is around 400 hours on one of our
more modest instances.
Alright. That is a housekeeping.
Today, I am joined by Andrew Martin, the
CEO of Control Plane.
Hello. Hello. I just I've looked up and
I've seen your big cheesy smile and I
was like,
I was like, I don't I won't say
anymore. Do you wanna tell us a little
bit about yourself? And then we'll get started
on today's session.
Sure. Yes. Hello. It's a delight to be
here. I'm Andy. I'm alcohol free at this
point in time.
I,
I promise.
And, yeah. Hi. I'm the CEO at Control
Plane. We are cloud native security,
which basically means, we do DevOps, and we
try to do it well because
DevSecOps and that layer above is just solid
engineering.
So very proud to have a very
smart bunch of colleagues,
doing interesting things. We have plenty of positions
open if people are interested,
of course.
And, yeah, my background is in low level
engineering and distributed systems.
I came into security as a product of
getting
access to these systems and realizing that there
was less than perfect coverage.
Of course, a hundred percent is never possible.
So I was just able to follow my
interest
and keep on going down rabbit holes and
untangling balls of twine.
So that's how we find ourselves here today.
Awesome. Thank you for sharing. So what are
you drinking? It looked like a beer. Oh.
Yeah. I mean, I I'm almost carbon neutral,
so I'm now trying to go alcohol neutral.
If
they would like to sponsor me, this is
the most crisp and beautiful of the
unfiltered lagers.
It is 0.5%.
Nice.
It's a couple of really nice alcohol free
beers that I like actually. The Erdinger one
is really, really nice. Mhmm. And the Brewdog
ones are are particularly tasty too.
Yeah. I Sorry. The the other silent magical
beer is the the Jupiter.
And for many years of drinking in Belgium,
I've accidentally bought cases of non alcoholic beer
before.
So now at the other end of my
existence, I'm happy to type it says actually
really quite good as lagers go. Nice. So
today,
we're taking a look at some of the
CTS scenarios
that you and your team at ControlPlay and
put together. Is it the KubeCon ones?
Yes. Indeed. It is the scenarios from
last week's
epic KubeCon, frankly. The, the livestreams that we
did, one of which you were a part
of, were just fantastic. Really thoroughly enjoyed doing
them, and
we didn't have enough time to finish everything.
So we will run through them all end
to end.
Awesome. Well, I actually didn't have a chance
to partake in the CTF
last week, except for what we did on
the the livestream in between where we had
a little play.
It definitely gave me a wee taste for
it. I like, oh, I should do more
of this stuff. So I'm really excited that
we actually get to sit down together and
do this together too. So
you have sent me some rather sketchy and
dubious bash stuff to stick in my shell,
which I did without blinking an eye. So
there we go. We're gonna see how we
get on today.
I've got this link from the CTF.
I mean, can people still do this on
their own time, or is this something that
they'd have to
send you a little money for?
There are two versions, of course. We are
open core for all of this. So there
is an open source project called Kubernetes
simulator,
and that fundamentally is a provisioning engine,
aka Terraform, of course,
and
a load of nefarious
scripts
that run through and misconfigure,
I guess, security contexts
and
the definitions of what's running in a pod
various
various other
things that miscreants may or may not take
advantage of.
So that open source piece
is used for the CTF. Yep. It is
beholden upon me to patch the changes back
into that, so that will be done next
week because I had to take a breather.
Yes. And
to actually run this at scale, we've built
a load of, distributed orchestration around it. So
we've run that for conferences. We've run that
privately as well.
But, centrally, all of the learning experience
is available through the simulator, and all the
scenarios that we ran for, KubeCon
twenty twenty north sorry, twenty twenty EU,
no. It was North America.
It's continental
confusion
are available on the open source version. So
everything will be there, but no one can
cheat for the CTF so we don't publish
them in advance. Got it. Perfect.
Alright. So
this is the dodgy stuff you sent me.
Untars
some configurations and SSHs me in
to something. So I'm just gonna
hit k s play, let it do its
thing,
and we are
n a shell,
either in a container, on a VM, and
somewhere. Right? Is that is that all I
need to know at this point in time?
That is a correct observation.
Each
the the penultimate well, the last line of
text there where your cursor is tells us
what the starting position is.
Actually, you're
you're kind of right about the layers of
abstraction,
but yeah, we only care that it's a
pod right now. Alright. Okay. So
I'm starting in a hashtag pod,
which is in some namespace.
It wants me to
follow the captain and prove out his attack
path to find a flag.
Alright. Yes. There is this
arch nemesis
sort of archetypal
sailor of the binary maelstrom,
and all this other nonsensical rubbish,
who is this character that I've constructed
to write a book around, essentially. So that
there's a book coming out in November
called Hacking Kubernetes.
And in order to give kind of threat
modeling and attacking stuff more teeth and something
a bit more realistic,
this guy, captain hashtag exists. You will see
on the fourth lineup how much effort I
put into the,
kind of UTF eight spelling of the word
Hashtag.
And joy of all joys, it renders in
our terminals.
Truly, we are in the future.
Yeah. So this guy, captain Hashjack,
has done numerous nefarious things with his motley
crew of scoundrels.
And the point of the CTF is to
chase down what he's done and understand how
he's performed these attacks
in order to
understand for ourselves how best we secure the
cluster, how we chop off those branches on
an attack tree,
and how we model the threat model
in an abstract sense and, of course, in
the concrete sense of actually putting these controls
in place.
Okay.
So should I just start pushing buttons or
Mhmm.
Yeah. Alright.
Okay. So I do see
a process table that makes me think we
are in a container.
Confirmed.
This looks like a host disk.
Alright.
So it appeared to me that we can
just mount the host disk.
That is entirely correct. The
the telltale signs here are the container runtime
would normally mask dev
and so not give us full access to
everything
that is available on the host. Because, of
course, dev is a virtual kernel file system.
It's provided because everything in Linux is a
file.
And in a container normally,
we would not see
lots of TTYs.
If we know David's not a big fan
of Unicode. Yeah. There was a custard episode
where
a fell
Scotsman actually, Guy Templeton
ruined broke the core DNS config by swapping
out the old for a Unicode old that
looked very much like it. Yeah.
That's the the original typo squatting, I guess.
Painful.
Anyway. Yeah. Big time.
Yeah. So so with normally some very restricted
but
but but yes, you are you're bang on.
This is exactly where we want to be.
So I guess
I mean, I've got access to the desk.
I can just share it this. I'm assuming
I've know
Kubernetes.
Yeah.
I've got the rootster. That's always a good
sign.
I've got ability to
speak to the cubelet or even probably modify
no. Thank you.
I was starting manifest. Alright. Okay.
So am I supposed to be looking for
a flag or am I just trying to
take the roots there? It's like,
I'm looking for something. Right? Yes. There are
flags littered across all the clusters.
In this case, there's only one.
Okay.
The, there's a vital piece of information which
I should, in the spirits of Fairplay, share
with you, and that's that the flags have
a well known format.
So flag underscore c t f, open curly
parentheses,
a hex block,
and then a close parenthesis.
So it is possible if you have the
time and inclination
to find these flags. Some of them,
it takes a a little bit longer to
find. So
sniffing around in some places is useful.
I mean, I just check things that I
would assume would probably be
obvious.
So what you'd like, I mean, I've never
done like a real CTF. Right? So if
I was partaking in this,
are there any hints or advice that you
would give to people? Like, what should actually
be doing? Like, once you get access to
the the root disk, other common
places, paths,
commands they should be running, things they should
be looking out for?
That's a really good question. The
playing a CTF
and avoiding
or evading intrusion detection,
are are quite different things. So if we
were actually attacking a host system that we
were,
we were red teaming, we had legitimate reason
to be, to be attacking
the system, of course,
which is the disclaimer on on all of
the the CTF stuff.
In that case,
we would probably be trying to tread quite
carefully. So we wouldn't necessarily be grepping for
stuff, although that is, frankly,
the the best way to solve a CTF
a lot of the time.
We would try and perhaps,
depending upon our level of, of defense evasion.
I was just watching,
we were doing a Sands call earlier,
and there was a really great presentation on
emerging threat actors,
and they popped up a SolarWinds slide.
The SolarWinds slide,
the the attack began
getting on for a year before they actually
dropped the Sunburst malware
the Sunspot malware. So they were super stealthy.
They were just doing one thing really cautiously
at a time
because,
I mean, you don't wanna trigger those alarm
systems.
In a CTF,
I haven't played a CTF with IDS. I
think it's it's a great idea and watch
out for next
KubeCon CTF, I guess.
But, yeah, in in this case,
speaking personally, I go and look in places
that,
I would drop things myself, I guess.
The root directory
is normally somewhere that an administrator
if I've just got a Snowflake server and,
as you and I can probably recall from
the days before wide automation and DevOps being
being a thing almost,
we used to have to go on servers,
and we used to have to move
keys around. We used to generate our certificates
from the server itself.
And the slash root directory
is
a it's a place where root trusts
they only have access.
Yeah. So so something in here is
likely to cause
cause problems for
a flag
defender maybe.
Alright. Well, I love that I could see
the kernel with AWS and I could set
the metadata API. That would be fun. But
I'm looking in this root thingy. And you
said
you wouldn't grab?
Why would you not grab? In a CTF,
I would.
Alright. But on on
a non
excellent work, sir.
Hate that I don't have my all complete.
I know.
Cdf
dot star.
Was
there was something there. There we go.
Very good. That is it. Oh, look. There's
more more UTF eight.
What a joy.
Alright.
So if you just if you grep for
the flag again Yeah. It's in the authorized
keys fail, wasn't it? Yeah. You got it.
That is bashing this thing. There we go.
So
the the flag is this nasty person has
added SSH keys to the authorized keys, so
they have access to the host going forward.
That is exactly it. Yes.
And this is one of the
one of the ways to achieve persistence if
you are just mounting the host file system.
Because, of course, without using NS enter, we've
only really technically charrooted or entered the the
host's mount namespace.
If you run a a PS again here,
you'll see you'll see it's still in the
container.
Oh, because of the bash. Yeah. Chirutz told
you the Oh. The the magic, I think.
Yeah. So so
yeah. Precisely. So you you're able to navigate
that file system and pull all the things
from it.
Mhmm. But but we're still yeah. Exactly. As
you see, we're still in the process namespace
of the container.
So the only namespace we've managed to break
into so far
is, is the mount namespace, and that means
to actually break out onto the host, we
need to do one of a few things.
The simplest
is,
well, let's say the simplest.
We can do what we've done here, which
is to drop
an author a public key into the host
dot SSH
authorized keys for root.
If we wanted to use that attack route
on a modern system, we'd also probably have
to enable route login
for for SSHD
because that's not always enabled anymore,
but we can do loads of things.
Interacting with system d units is a bit
more difficult, of course. Sorry to interrupt.
I I was I was only gonna say
we we have access to the etcetera kubernetes.
We have access to the kubelet in the
static pod manifest.
So we mean, we could run a privilege
pod in there,
which would get us access to the all
the namespaces on the host.
Yes. If we had n a center in
that pod, then we could just blaze into
all the namespaces.
But because we've just because we're in a
pod with that, slash dev access,
which is normally
because it's privileged anyway,
That's the route we've taken. But, yeah, exactly
as you say, we could just run another
container. Mhmm. We could just drop in a
shadow pod that
has the tooling that we want to break
out onto the host. We could drop in
a cron job, which fires off a reverse
shell.
We could mess with some of the system
d units, although they might need a daemon
reload and that would take longer.
It's game over for multiple different games simultaneously.
Nice.
Super cool. Excellent work. Okay. Let us progress.
Alright. Do I need do I need new
stack new things? Or am I done with
this shell?
Yes. That shell is
thoroughly popped
and no longer very used to us.
So
here we go.
And this highly advanced,
tar g z based
access provisioning mode is is how we run
the
the KubeCon CTF as well. And all credit
to the attendees,
many of them did question
what do we think we were doing,
just throwing around bits of bash and tarballs,
which is put
it on a USB
key and give it to them. Right?
It's coming in by pigeon.
Alright. So we're now in a second
shell. I'm assuming like what,
you know, the new people they're joining c
test. Right? The first five commands you should
run. I'm assuming are look at the processes,
look at the main points, look at
maybe wanna see if you've got an sophisticated
network or no access to the network. Like,
what would what would you run beyond that?
Yeah. That that's awesome. I
I have some useful collateral that I will
share in a second. Alright. But but the
first thing is just to exactly like you
say, check the mount points because they bleed
so much of the abstraction of a container.
From there, it's worth checking.
We can see in in the process table
if
if we are actually in a process namespace.
Yeah. Precisely. So all good.
The the network as well is super useful.
We should be we should have a pod
well, rather, we should have a local Ethernet
adapter
that is on something that looks like a
private range.
It should probably also look like quite a
small range because we assume it's a pod
network.
If it's not, then maybe we've got access
to the host adapter.
There's also a super useful, bit of kernel
jiggery pokery that
we can do. So because we're,
I I I checked ID as well just
to see,
what,
what we are. Okay. So
if we now cat proc self
status,
then we can see some stuff in here
that also looks a bit like what AMI
contained brings us.
AMI contained is the canonical
internal container observability
tool written by Jess Fraz, who just shipped
all the container security stuff right at the
beginning.
But we do have to pull a binary
into our pod if we want to run
am I contained. So proc self status will
tell us quite a lot of things.
We can see that we have no set
comp enabled on the, like, seventh or eighth
line up there.
We can see some of the capabilities that
we've got.
Although broadly,
I I don't decode those.
And then if we go up,
there is,
we can see the UID. Of course, we
can see that through ID as well.
And it's some interesting information.
To take this to the next level, the
AMI contained tool,
which will run, in a in a later
attack,
will also tell us it will take a
best guess at which,
which container orchestrator we're in. So let's try
and guess which orchestrator we're in. Well,
that wouldn't be doing justice to clustered
and its obvious spelling
hints perhaps.
But if we cat
proc self
c groups
singular. Sorry.
Then we can see that the name of
the c groups that have been created
also give us a bit of a clue.
And it's all this stuff around leaking abstractions
that
make containers
at once super fast to spin up and
beneficial and portable and useful,
but then they're not a perfect abstraction.
Okay.
So is that the first the first thing
to do is really just to gather as
much information as you can before trying to
move towards the flag. Right?
Yeah. Exactly.
Alright. I'm I'm gonna show my naivety here.
I didn't see anything here to reveal maybe
what CRI implementation we were using. I do
see system d and freezer.
Does that mean we're using container d?
That's a really good point, actually. If
these are stood up I I mean, yes
is the answer, but
I'm not I'm not convinced that
I'm not sure that queue pods changes for
different run times. I haven't I I can't
actually tell you that offhand. Certainly, if we
were to run this via Docker, it would
tell us that we're in Docker there. Right.
Okay. So
I I think you're you're definitely on the
right path.
Yeah. I've
that's how I handle most things. I just
say I don't know and guess. So
but I should just be prodding around. Right?
This is
I did see the mounts were
It looks like we've maybe got access to
the host again that way.
Yeah.
Maybe let's see.
Oh no, we don't. Okay.
That's how it should look.
Alright. So what do we have then?
Not a whole lot on this one.
Is there I I don't know what system
this is.
Well, let's see if I can work that
out. Maybe that'll help me. Not an LSB
file normally.
I'd like to go asterisk
rel into asterisk.
And that yeah. That's it. Oh, actually. Yeah.
Alright. Okay.
But it's a bit different for different I
mean, older OSs don't quite have it. So
that star rel always tends to work. Nice.
Yeah. I normally look for the l s
p underscore release, but I guess star rail
would cover that too. So
handy.
Alright. So
Yeah. When
you started off, you used the mount command.
Mhmm. Which is super useful because
it gives you all that extra context.
And and if we go right to the
top
I say right to the top, just slightly
further up, then it also leaks the overlay
f s. Yeah. Exactly. Yeah. There's the docker
run time as well. Yeah. Okay.
And and so so that gives us a
bit more
it's just something else that's leaking.
However, this is super noisy because it tells
us things about where c groups are mounted.
So I always run both mount and also
d f.
And that tends to scream a bit louder
when there is a service count.
Yeah. We've got the secret in here.
And it's kind of most of the time,
people don't unmount the default service account,
which is obviously not a great look.
It also means that a service account may
just be
unable to do very much by default, let's
say. Someone else who came to left me
control in this container.
Yes.
Sometimes thinking of the user.
Does that mean I can run
oh, look at that.
Bazinga.
At
least there's some RBAC going on. Oh,
we got some crypto miners going on as
well. That's fun. That is the badger.
And the the context for this is that
we've got unexpected workloads.
Now notably,
just some background with this one, the
this is more about
attacking Kubernetes'
workloads
and
side effects rather than misconfigurations of the orchestrator.
Doesn't really mean very much, does it?
Okay.
So I need to work out what my
next move is. Right?
Yes.
I I can start
poking around.
I could start exactly into other pods
looking for maybe better privileges
like
in the interest of time.
Yeah. What should I do?
Those pods should not be running and stealing
our compute resource. Let's shoot them in the
head.
Oh, wait. Are we the good guys or
the bad guys? I thought I was trying
to get ripped.
We're the good guys following
the bad guys. And this is what the
bad guys have done. Okay.
There are a good number of routes targeted
flags, but this is not all of them.
Okay. So we wanna delete some pods.
I was gonna spin up some more, but
whatever.
You've you've
avoided the mistake that is easy to make,
which is we are in fact in the
hashtag pod.
Yes.
Because my my first instinct was to do
a delete pod dash dash all and I
thought,
no, I'm in this namespace.
So
although now that I've just realized I've deleted
pods, which is probably rather silly because they
are tuples, which would suggest
there may be something else
get deployed.
Deployment.
I don't have access to that.
But if you check the pods Yeah. They
are coming back. So
not stateful sets.
It could be daemon sets.
I don't have access to that.
You're very much in the right direction.
Right. Okay. So my my goal is to
get rid of all these pods.
Yeah. And between you and me, they are
demon sets. No. They're not.
That's instinctive. I'm so sorry. No. They're deployments.
Alright. But I don't have the access
to list the deployments on my current privileges.
But you could probably
elucidate
their names.
Oh, so I just don't have list access.
Yeah. That's right.
Oh, look at that. Alright.
Incidentally,
I'm looking to launch all of those coins.
Really, I should have been a bit smarter
and just says,
auth can I list?
And I would have seen
that I can delete very nicely left as
a hint there. I was just being rather
silly, but there we go. Got it.
So that should mean they're all gone at
least now.
Getting
there. Is
that it? Is it done?
Almost. Almost. At the point that they make
themselves scarce,
something will probably turn up in secrets.
Oh, there was a hashtag secret. I looked
at that earlier. Oh, there's a flag. Alright.
Okay. I think, potentially, this is managed by
the world's
oh, gonna make a big claim. The world's
shortest
operator,
perhaps?
I found my flag.
Oh, the one I missed there.
There you go.
Excellent.
Excellent work.
Okay. Let's keep on rolling.
Here is your next scenario.
So in this scenario,
we have
we're running internal container registries,
and the pirates have turned up,
taken the registry down,
and left a secret in one of the
pods.
So this is a
this is a kind of
screaming backflip through a flaming hoop kind of
exploit,
where, again, we're just using what Kubernetes gives
us
in an unusual way. So is it hacking?
Well,
of of a sorts.
Okay. I don't wanna run that, but
echo hashtag.
Okay.
Is that important? Should I be looking at
that or is that just there for the
is that an Easter egg?
Yes. It is not important for It's not
important. I
was hoping you were gonna wreck Rawkode me,
but
Just you wait, perhaps.
Alright. So I can see Docker CRI again.
We have our overlay.
We've got our secrets. We've got some disks.
We
have a service account.
No IP command.
Alright.
So
Do we have control?
We do.
People are always nice leaving all these tools
lying around.
It was a yeah. Feedback from last time
perhaps.
So they have to curl down the binary
in every single pod.
Alright. Let's see what I have access to
here.
Well, we can create deployments.
We can get logs,
but we can
get pods too. Okay.
Let's see what else we have.
Namespaced,
private tier one, two and three.
We do not have the ability to exec
into another pod.
So I'm assuming
we're create
do you want me to create something? Is
that why I have the ability to create
create deployments?
Yeah. That's it. There's
the interesting thing here is the contents of
the image.
We can't get to that image,
but we can run a pod using that
image as the base.
So it's then about and this is the,
the screaming backflip.
It's then about trying to
it it's almost a blind injection attack.
It's not quite it is blind because we
can't see the file system contents.
It's kind of an injection,
but we are still just running kube control.
So that's perhaps a overly dramatic wording.
But if we
if we have a look at what's running
in those private ear pods,
so dumping them as as YAML and grepping
for image.
They are running
Excalibur.
That is the badger.
So the goal here is to
run a pod using that image. Do you
maintain your own registry?
This is the the secret internal
registry for the purpose of this. Alright. The
answer is absolutely not.
Sorry. I cut you off. Okay. So No.
No. It's all good.
Right. Let's
push me along a little bit here. I'm
not sure what my next move is.
So what we want to try is cube
control run
and
set the image to be
that crazy,
practical image.
And then
yes. Nice. We
want do we want a terminal? I'm not
sure. Maybe just try double double hyphen.
I'm not sure if we yeah. Okay.
And then
I don't know if IT will work on
the run, but I figured I'd try it.
It's it's worth trying. Yeah.
What's there?
Yeah. I can't end because I don't have
blood exec.
Checking a thought was gonna happen.
So the way that we can do this
semi blind maybe it's kind of monocalled half
injection
is
to check the log outputs.
And the the the tool that I really
love for logging is called Stern
from, a company called Worker that Oracle bought,
like, three years ago.
But this tool Stern,
I'll drop a link in, allows us to
essentially specify a wildcard that lets us grep
across any existing or future pods in any
or all namespaces.
We can't do that right now. We'll just
have to use cube control logs. Well, we
could, but let's not bother.
And
okay.
So where are we?
I have to admit missing the previous command.
Sorry. I was running the logs against our
hashtag too, but I don't seem to be
getting
anything back out. And then I just decided
to check the logs of private tier one,
two, three, but let's just sleep.
Oh, yeah. It's going round in circles. Okay.
Let's have a look at this injection command.
Could you pull up the cube control run
again, please?
Yep.
Yeah.
This. Okay.
So if
we replace bash if if I could get
bash
let me think about this. If if you
can remove the IT as well, because I
don't think we need an interactive terminal
for what we'll do, and then double hyphen.
And then we'll we'll run bash again, bash
space hyphen c,
and then just put an ID in there
and see what happens.
Alright.
Okay. Gotcha.
And we've got a fun game here because
we need a unique Yeah. Pod name, of
course, every time we do an injection.
So, yes, apologies. This is where Stern is
useful.
Alright. Rip, Rip, and Rip.
Cool.
Okay.
So Noel has very helpfully posted,
another useful GREP. So if we replace ID
with
the GREP r flag CTF
search,
then we will find
and I think, again, for the purposes of
of speed searching in user share.
So up to, please.
That's the badger. And then,
just Noel's last, last chat in the
that's the badger again.
And then if we use user share as
instead of the root slash.
That looks good to me.
Joyful joys.
And we have a flag.
Very nice indeed.
Interesting points to note here.
The rickroll will be from a different line
of the song every time.
If you actually
and why
under god's bright sun would anybody ever create
a directory name, which is a comma?
Who who only knows?
But, yes, congratulations.
We are rocking through the flags.
On we go to the next one.
There we go. Thank you.
And we are in number four.
Very nice. Now it occurs to me because
of my exceptional timing,
I may,
this cluster may self destruct around this. Can
you just check?
This is an interesting experiment. What does uptime
say?
55.
So this is this will go in a
a blaze of glory very shortly. There's another
one coming up, so we'll be able to
transition between clusters
semi seamlessly.
But let's
You can send me the my
service
account again. I'm assuming we're gonna be following
the same pattern here.
Let's just go straight in there.
Oh, that's ripped.
Yeah. Loved into a false sense of insecurity,
I'm afraid.
Alright. The the
back chat for this one is the supply
chain is compromised,
and code has been merged into an application
library that developers use.
The library runs in the in a pod.
Attackers have used
that reverse
shell that the pod threw to jump into
the pod
and find secrets
mounted on the host.
So somehow, we need to get out of
this pod
and, and into a mount point.
Okay.
Cool.
And we have four minutes.
And I
and I have to say, I, again,
lulled you somewhere because if you go back
to the PS at the top
now earlier on, we both jumped into the
same pod, and that meant that we had
two bash sessions
the two bash processes running. Actually, what we've
got here with two sleep sessions,
processes
is
potentially an indicator
of misconfiguration.
Okay.
Oh, there we go.
Oops. See you later. Okay. What should we
do?
We will have the next one up very
shortly. And if you just
okay. Yes. So so just looking at that.
We've
the the first thing to do, please, is
to scroll back up to the, description.
And and then just slightly further down.
Now just before we've typed uptime,
it says use kube control, describe, blah blah
blah to see all of the containers in
this pod. And the line above that,
defaulting container name to audit,
that comes from kubectl exec.
That is not part of the scenario description.
And probably in the spirit of fairness and
goodwill,
I should put a dividing line between the
two so that's clear.
Right. But concretely,
what that means is there's more than one
container
in the pod.
KubeControl used to
not tell you this information
when, when you jumped in or or give
you less information.
But now with kind of one two one
Yeah. Yeah. That's that does you can set
the default container now. Right?
Yeah. So it and we go toward it.
But, actually,
the,
the container that we're looking for
is in the same pod
and somehow accessible.
And that's, suitably vague,
not be of any further use without a
cluster as well.
I don't know if we've got any more.
So if I just send you one that
we've
been
let's, let's reverse back to the last cluster.
We only need another couple of minutes before
this comes back up again,
but at least we'll have something to poke
around that mind you saying that, they were
probably all spun up at the same time.
This is where I miss Lewis.
He never makes these kind of rudimentary mistakes.
Alright.
So I'm deleting the old cluster, and you
want me to redownload the previous cluster, which
you've just sent me. I'll do that now.
Although we suspect that that one may also
go kaboom.
Yes. Which is nice because I'm actually I'm
wearing my Marvin the Martian t shirt today.
So things gone kaboom is encouraged.
It's only up ninety minutes. There we go.
Well, that's
is that what you expected?
Yes. Because I was better at the beginning
of this
video than I am at the end.
So this might be an interesting time to
pull am I contained?
Fortunately,
Jess does an awesome job on the releases
page.
Genuine tools, am I contained?
That's the badger.
And if you go straight to releases, she
gives you a checksum validation.
I mean, this is how software should be
delivered. Right? Everybody who is running code cove
and not checking
and when I say everybody,
everybody,
even up to HashiCorp,
the big boys.
So
we've got a permission denied. This is totally
standard in containers.
We often can't hit the file system locations
that we want,
but what we can do is
yeah. You got it. We can write to
temp, and that's
we can
we can grep the mount points for the
string RW,
and that will just tell us if we've
got a mount if we've a writable mount.
As long as we don't have no dev
Oh, wait. I was trying to download. Oh,
there we go. Let's Yeah. Repeat that.
And
the before as well Yep.
Twice.
So this kind of cat and mouse game
of immutability on partitions
is really not solvable. Applications need to drop
PID files, lock files. They probably need temporary
disk. You've probably got access to dev SHM,
shared memory segment.
Really, even GKE, which is super hardened and
well configured by default,
you can still find places to write runnable
files.
It becomes a lot easier to IDS detect
the thing,
but boom. Okay. Awesome.
So if we remember what we had in
self status,
we've got a a lot more visibility here.
We can see has namespaces pid? Yes. That's
a good thing. Username spaces, no. Hardly anybody
has username spaces right now because
they're very complex. They cut across a lot
of other namespaces because everything is a file,
and every file must have, discretionary access control,
users and groups, and blah blah blah.
Doing
a lot of work to bring usernamespaces
to
Flatcar,
which is the spiritual successor of container Linux
or CoreOS as it used to be. That
will be super awesome when they ship that.
What else do we have here? AppArmor profile,
docker default.
You beauty.
Very rarely is AppArmor on by default in
Kubernetes,
so this is a very happy day.
And we can see our bounding sets of
capabilities.
This will give us an indication
whether we're privileged to start off with,
but but also tell us things like we've
got deck overrides. That means we can change
permissions on files in the same way we
can with churn.
We can make nodes. We can do routes.
We we've got a lot going on in
there.
And then
yep. Sorry.
No. No. I was just agreeing. Yeah. Stuff.
Thanks.
App Armour, SC Linux, love all that stuff.
It's so easy to operate these days in
2021.
Tell me about it. And this is where
the vendors make the money.
Yeah. There's there are loads of things that
I I know are just good practice, but
then,
you know,
it's
hard.
Big time. Yeah.
There's there there are tools that will extract
runtime security profiles from running applications.
But unless those applications exercise the full sets
of production runtime behaviors,
they're not gonna build the right security profile.
So there's this mysterious
gray area
wherever
a security operates, I suppose.
And often,
there there's some awesome tooling that's come out
to support this, actually.
The, Aqua Tracy
does some of this stuff. Red Red Hat
have a,
but they have multiple things. They have,
a man, I'm just I have tool override.
So there there's a there there's a tool
that will use eBPF to trace system calls
to generate profiles.
And Oh, nice.
And so could maybe do bits of that
as well if you got that running on
your cluster.
It's absolutely the same space. Yeah.
I guess Falca reverse engineer.
Yeah. And seccomp, I think, you know, with
the seccomp operator and all the work that
Dan and Sasha are doing there, it's it's
getting a lot easier to run seccomp on
Kubernetes as well, which is which is nice.
I just wish people would do that for
AppArmor and SE Linux. Otherwise, I I'd maybe
stop disabling them.
Dan wolf's cries every time someone disables
extract SELinux profiles from deny events,
similar to Audit to RBAC that Jordan Leggett
built.
I just can't remember what it's called.
I'm sure someone will find it.
I think Noel has come in. Is it
Bain?
Yeah. But Bain's great, but it's actually a
a preprocessor
for,
for AppArmor, I think.
He says, not having used it like that.
So perhaps Oh, I think I missed his
first comment. So I think that's also from
Jess Rizzell, and it's a tool for dynamically
generated tech comp profiles for a binary, which
is nice.
Or unless I've just stashed two random comments
together that aren't related.
It's it's in the right direction.
Bain focuses on AppArmor,
and it's less of a reverse engineer. It's
more of a a DSL. So you can
just so you don't have to write AppArmor,
basically. You can write kind of higher order
language and and have it compiled down.
But, yeah, I I mean, the this is
where container security vendors the next cluster's with
you, by the way. This is where container
security vendors have been operating for the past,
like,
five, seven
what year is it? Eight years.
And
another great I'm just dropping stats that I
heard in a call earlier.
Security operation centers that use open source tooling
have a markedly higher
talent retention rates.
People like open source.
Yeah. True.
It's awesome.
Alright.
So we're getting close to the hour, and
I know your calendar is always a nightmare.
So I don't want us to go over
that hour. So why don't you guide us
through this one if we can do it
in the next five minutes and then we'll
do a quick wrap up and then
maybe I can schedule more of your time
in the future to do a bit more
CTFE fun. Absolutely.
SE Linux audit to allow is the one.
Good spot. We'll lead. Okay. So what are
we doing here?
We are So you've told me that we
have a second container and this
pod and we need to find a way
to get access to the other container. Right?
Yes. That is entirely correct.
No. I know that pods
share
the net namespace but I don't seem to
see
any way to confirm that, I guess.
So
yeah. I'll You're
totally in the right kind of area. Right.
Okay. Go for it.
Because we've got those two sleep pods,
we want to just have a poke around.
And while PS shows us that we are
in a process namespace,
the question is who else is in our
process namespace?
By default, Kubernetes containers
in a pod are in the same network
namespace, the same interprocess namespace,
but not the same
mount namespace,
and not the same,
and they have their own container file systems,
of course, and not the same process namespace.
In this case, we have a shared process
namespace between containers and a pod.
So if we go cat proc
because 12 is the pit of the other
sleep process.
And we could probably have found that by
just doing an LS and seeing that we
have a few numbers here.
So
is that how you would have done it?
Yes. It should always correlate to It would
have shown me it here. Right? You got
it.
See, sometimes I take the hard road. I
don't think Right. Okay. Sorry. We're in prog
12. Cool.
Okay. So what we can do from here
is see the root file system of the
other process.
So if we let's start with cat and
go into root, please.
Just
yeah.
Root within this directory. Alright.
And then just start auto completing.
So we've now got the root file system
of the other container because
the PID that is running in the other
process namespace
is now leaking back to us as well.
This is by design. It's What? It's necessary.
It's because we've shared the process namespace between
the pods the containers in a pod.
So, I mean,
I would say I'm relatively familiar with the
product namespace, and I had no idea you
could navigate the root file system for each
process in this way.
Okay. Normally, this is a highly I mean,
we we're roots, so we we have access
to privileged system stuff.
And from here,
where do we want to go? This one,
you may want to look in temp. So
in the temp directory of the other container,
and then into temp again,
and then into logs again. You might just
want to also complete for a bit.
Oh.
I should have just said no. Read them
all out to me one by one.
Yeah. I I feel bad that I've used
the same, file name twice.
The directory name rather.
There we go.
Excellent.
Fantastic.
Yet there are two more,
and there is a, a mysterious bounty flag
hidden later. So
let's let's cut it off there and find
the time to get the others through and
then maybe run through some of last year's
as well.
Alright. Well,
thank you very much. Like,
I'm learning scary stuff, which is always a
wonderful thing to be doing. Like, that route
director and the prog thing. I I took
that that's wild.
I I don't know why that's a thing,
but I'm gonna have I'm gonna I'm gonna
have to look look that up for sure.
It's
a thing because when the kernel and I'm
I'm gonna butcher this, and please, colonel devs,
correct me.
But when the kernel is managing processes,
it wants all of that information so that
it can do its own introspection.
They're just SIM links to places.
Everything in Linux is a file, so it
makes that all available through the proc virtual
file system.
When we're root inside the container, and here's
the you know, just say this sort of
blur in the face, we have access to
all those privileged operations.
And so root inside the container can do
an awful lot because we're still just using
Linux, and that's why we want to elevate
to a non root user.
And would that be something that disappears with
user namespaces?
At least
user namespaces perform
oh, man. It's a mouthful. Subordinate group and
user mapping.
So where we've got kind of we used
to have one to 64 k. We've now
got one to 2,000,000,000,
possible user IDs.
There's so many because you can then so
you've got your root user namespace. You can
then create another user namespace on top, and
that maps
zero inside that namespace to 50,000
on the host. And then you can do
that again, and you can do it to
a point of brain melting complexity that we
won't think about.
So does it go away with these namespaces?
Some of the privileged host mounting stuff does
go away because we need that permission on
the in the the root's username space. What
we did just now
oh, that's by
design in inverted commas.
Cool. Alright. Well, I'll definitely be losing sleep
and turning off all of my production infrastructure
tonight. You
did a great job. Alright. Well, again, thank
you for taking some time out of your
day and walking us through this today. It
was great fun. I definitely am gonna get
more involved with CTS, I think, and just
use them as a learning experience. I think
this is a really fun and engaging way
to learn
really lower level components of the kernel and
containers that I've probably just been neglecting for
a while. So,
Andy, it's always a pleasure, but thanks again.
Have a great evening and I will speak
to you soon.
Cheers.
Totally enjoyed.